all right let's talk about another big
TV event yes people are buzzing yeah you
are but let's be honest yes they're
buzzing over last night's debut a fast
singer my agent begged me not to do this
show Buffy runs the truck I mean puffy
and that's how I knew it was gonna be a
hit
ratings prove it over nine million
viewers made the masked singer Wednesday
night's number-one show as the audience
judging panel and hosts Nick Cannon
tried to figure out who's singing behind
these disguises looking at their neck I
know that Nick awesomeness burns
Pittsburgh Steeler and former dancing
contestant Antonio Brown was the first
to be unmasked and despite their best
guesses I think there might be an
athlete here no one got it panelists
aren't even allowed to deliberate
backstage they like try to ban us from
talking to each other because they don't
want us to get an EP revealed more
layers of secrecy contestants arrived to
the taping in masks after being picked
up at a neutral location not their homes
on set they remain masked in a cordoned
off area only 7 staffers know who they
are not only are they covered but their
entire team they go above and beyond to
keep it a secret even early screening
copies of the show given to press hid
the celebs identities but pay close
attention to the costumes that's another
show secret the clues are actually
somehow put in by the designers and the
celebrities themselves contestants
helped design them to reveal pieces of
their identity it could be from Hawaii
like to fake working out I don't know
six more compete next week and for one
panelists an upcoming reveal gets
personal when somebody was revealed the
other night someone on the panel was
like oh my gosh I worked with you it's
good right now the talent they're going
to unmask on the show is pretty
impressive the singers have a combined
get this 65 Grammy Award nominations 16
Emmy Award nominations and four stars on
the Hollywood Walk of do you know
something that we don't I don't know
anything you were there I know listen
I'm here for the lion whoever the lion
is I'm
you have my vote
[Music]
[Applause]